en una toma por la fuerza efectivos de
la guardia nacional bolivariana tomaron
control de las edificaciones de el
nacional en caracas una decisión que la
justicia venezolana anunció en medio de
una demanda presentada por diosdado
cabello contra el periódico el número 2
del chavismo acusó al rotativo de daño
moral por haberse hecho eco de una
información del diario español abc que
señalaba a cabello de tener nexos con el
narcotráfico informó que en horas de la
tarde los tribunales competentes dentro
de los trámites de mi demanda el
nacional han ejecutado las medidas de
fijación de carteles y notificación de
embargo ejecutivo y se ha iniciado el
proceso de pago de la indemnización es
una indemnización de 13 millones de
dólares ordenada en abril y que el
nacional no tiene capacidad para pagar
dicen sus directivos su gerente explicó
a france 24 que no tienen más recursos
legales a los que acudir en este momento
no hay otra situación legal o atracción
legal que se pueda para sencillamente
responder informando
imprimir llenando de periódicos y de
información la calle porque la libertad
expresión jamás debe parar fundado hace
más de 75 años el nacional llegó a tener
ediciones de 72 páginas y con varias
revistas a finales de 2018 dejó de
imprimirse después de años sufriendo
dificultades para obtener insumos como
el papel el ocaso para un diario que hoy
ve aún más oscuro su horizonte